Hey everyone! We are going to take a look at the monopoly model and the implications that it has on societal welfare when compared to the competitive firm. Let's go ahead and jump into our monopoly model. So we start with our price and quantity axis. Let's add in a demand curve and a marginal cost curve and notice that the marginal cost curve is upward sloping like what we saw with the competitive firm then we have a downward-sloping marginal revenue curve. This is different than the competitive firm in which the demand curve was equal to marginal revenue curve and those were both horizontal at the price being charged here.
We still equate the marginal cost and marginal revenue to find the profit-maximizing or loss-minimizing output. When we do this for the Monopoly we end up with 100 units at a price of $15. Notice what we have to do. First we go to our marginal revenue equals are marginal cost point where those two curves intersect and then we keep going up until we hit our demand curve. This is how the Monopoly figures out the price that it's going to charge.
Now let's add in the average cost curve and we're going to go from the quantity axis up to the average cost curve. Once we hit that curve go over to the price axis and that is the price that we are, or excuse me, the average cost per unit
that we see with this monopoly. So what we now can do is figure out what the monopoly earns in economic profit. Here we do 15 - 10 * the total number of units being sold and we have a monopoly profit off of $500.
We can also look at the monopoly when it is loss minimizing. And to do that we have to have the average cost curve be above the demand curve. Now we have an average cost per unit of $18 but the price that we are still charging is $15.
So this gives us an economic loss of - $300. The Monopoly would not want to deviate away from that output level of 100--the same as what the competitive firm does. You both profit maximize and loss minimize wherever your marginal cost equals your marginal revenue.
Now, we do have one thing that we want to really pay attention to and that is the welfare implications of the monopoly because the monopoly has a price that is greater than the marginal revenue unlike the competitive firm. We are going to have some welfare loss in this model. Let's look at what happens here. We now have the black triangle in a peculiar area. Notice where it's located. It is bound by the demand curve, the marginal revenue curve, and the marginal cost curve. And the reason why we see this is because this is a thing called deadweight loss. That is if this was the competitive firm all the efficiency that goes along with the competitive market would be there.
But we now see is a situation in which the monopoly causes inefficiencies inside of this market. What does that mean? That means that there is some level of output that would exist if we equated our marginal cost curve, which is the supply curve for the competitive market, to the demand curve
which is the marginal revenue for the competitive firm. So, here we have demand equals marginal cost and that gives us an output level of 150.
Before we had an output level of only 100. So, there's 50 extra units of output that could be bought if the monopoly chose to have the competitive outcome, but the monopoly doesn't. The monopoly charges a higher price and this deadweight loss because people who are inside this market, their consumer surplus is lower than what it would be the competitive firm, which is what we see right here.
Now, we charge a price of $11 instead of the price of $15. And our consumer surplus and our producer surplus would both be maximized. But as it is, in the monopoly market we do not see that.
And here you can also see what we have is zero economic profit just because that average cost intersects the marginal cost at the price being charged by the market.
Alright! That is it for the monopoly model and welfare implications. Hope you have enjoyed it and I'll catch you in the next one.